hallo herzlich willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr mit dabei seid der
ukrainischen Armee ist offenbar ein
empfindlicher Schlag gegen Russlands
gelungen das Hauptquartier der
russischen Schwarzmeerflotte ist von
einer ukrainischen Rakete getroffen
worden es liegt auf der Halbinsel Krim
die von Russland ja völkerrechtswidrig
annektiert worden war hier sehen wir
jetzt die Bilder von dem brennenden
Gebäude das Ausmaß der Schäden ist
bisher unklar der von Russland
eingesetzt die Gouverneur sagte
Informationen über mögliche Opfer würden
geprüft
ja und auch von der Front an der Front
tut sich einiges im Südosten der Ukraine
im Gebiet saporicia wurden ukrainische
Panzer erstmals hinter dem breiten
russischen
Verteidigungsgürtel abwehrgürtel
gesichtet Kiew meldet außerdem Vorstöße
bei bachmut im Osten und im Südosten des
Landes bricht da gerade Putins Front wie
kommen die ukrainischen gegen Offensive
voran wie steht es um die militärische
Unterstützung und wie bereiten sich die
Menschen in der Ukraine auf den Winter
vor darüber spreche ich gleich mit dem
militär-experten Christian Mölling mit
unserem USA Korrespondenten elmarsen von
dort hören wir nämlich gerade dass die
USA der Ukraine nun doch attackens
Raketen liefern will und wir zeigen
gleich zu meiner Kollegin Alissa Jungen
nach Kiel wie immer Geld für euch eure
Gedanken und Fragen zum Thema könnt ihr
gerne hier direkt im Chat teilen oder
ihr schickt sie uns per Mail an sie
unten eingeblendete mehr Adresse ZDF
heute - live.at zdf.de
so wir wollen jetzt erstmal darüber
sprechen was da auf der Krim passiert
ist und zwar den Raketeneinschlag in
Sevastopol und das mache ich jetzt mit
dem Militärexperten Christian Mölling er
ist stellvertretender Direktor des
Forschungsinstituts der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik und
Leiter des Zentrums für Sicherheit und
Verteidigung hallo herrling hallo
gelernte Wortmann ja eine ukrainische
Rakete trifft offenbar das Hauptquartier
der russischen Schwarzmeerflotte ist das
aus ukrainischer Perspektive ein
militärischer Erfolg
da sieht man noch abwarten müssen was
die seines sogar damage assessment
bringt es gibt Gerüchte darüber dass zu
dem Zeitpunkt ein wichtiges Treffen in
dem Hauptquartier stattgefunden hat es
ist aber insofern schon auf alle Fälle
ein politischer Erfolg weil man damit
demonstriert das nicht einmal das
Hauptquartier der Schwarzmeerflotte
offensichtlich effektiv noch durch
Russland geschützt werden kann
nehmen Sie uns gerne einmal mit warum
ist über die Krim wurde in den
vergangenen Monaten ja immer viel
gesprochen aber warum ist Sebastopol ein
so strategisch wichtiges Ziel also was
du cool ist der Haupthafen der
Schwarzmeerflotte auch traditionell ganz
lange die russischer und sowjetischer
Hafen gewesen
etwas wo die Flotte auch selbst zu einem
gewissen Teil heute noch anwesend ist
von daher ist das natürlich ein ein
Schlag nicht nur gegen einen militärisch
sondern auch historisches Ziel dass die
Russen lange mit sich selber und mit der
Sowjet Zeit verbunden haben und wir
haben ja eben auch auf der Karte sehen
können dass es sehr weit im Südwesten
liegt das heißt also man ist in der Lage
nahezu alle Ziele auf der Krim zu
treffen auch das ist ein Teil der
Nachricht gesendet wird
sie sagen es ist ein sehr wichtiges Ziel
warum gelingt es der Ukraine bzw warum
gelingt es Russland so es ist richtig
dann diesen Punkt diesen Ort des
Hauptquartier nicht besser zu schützen
also offensichtlich ist die Ukraine in
den letzten Wochen das haben wir alle
miterlebt immer in einzelnachrichten
sehr erfolgreich gewesen die Luftabwehr
die Luftverteidigung rund um die
Sebastopol auszuschalten es hat auch
gestern schon den Treffer in einem
Kommunikationszentrum gegeben das 17 km
entfernt ist von Sebastopol also hier
muss man glaube ich einfach die die
einzelnen Tagesmeldung zusammen nehmen
und sagen die Krim ist mittlerweile ich
will nicht sagen in das Zentrum gerückt
aber es ist ein wesentlicher Teil der
Angriffsziele der Ukraine zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt und ich glaube es deutet
darauf hin dass wir langsam aber sicher
auf die Hochphase der Offensive zu
laufen
geht es dann dabei tatsächlich bei
dieser Hochphase der Offensive auch wenn
wir jetzt auf die Krim schauen um eine
Rückeroberung der Krim oder vielleicht
viel mehr darum den Russen da den
Nachschub abzuschneiden
ich glaube bei den Treffern geht es
nicht so sehr um den Nachschub dafür ist
dir was zu Polen nicht wichtig so was zu
tun könnte wichtig werden oder zumindest
die Schiffe die dort liegen wenn die
Russen sich zurückziehen müssten von der
Krim oder aus aus dem Süden der Ukraine
das könnte auch einen Fall sein hier
geht es eigentlich eher darum die Krim
auch in den Augen Russlands so
militärisch und haltbar zu machen dass
man sich an den Verhandlungstisch bewegt
das ist ja das was selenskin seinen
Friedensplan noch mal deutlich gemacht
hat und ist bereit über die Ukraine zu
verhandeln über die Krim zu verhandeln
man muss es nicht mit einem
militärischen Sieg sozusagen zu Ende
gehen lassen gleichzeitig steht halt
dahinter natürlich auch die Nachricht
wenn Russland sich nicht zurückzieht von
der krimin dann wird natürlich der
angeht weitergehen weil die krimteile
Ukraine ist
Herr merling wir hören heute außerdem
das ist laut russischen Behörden auf der
Krim zu einem Zitat beispiellosen
Cyberangriff gekommen sei was kann ein
solcher Cyberangriff da tatsächlich
bewirken
das hängt von den einzelnen Details ab
die ich jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht kenne aber zu glauben dass ein
Cyberangriff nur dazu führt dass Ihr
Computer nicht mehr geht ist halt falsch
in Zeiten in denen softwareen
wesentlicher Bestandteil auch von
militärischen Operationen ist das heißt
wir müssen etwas genauer wissen was
passiert ist aber man kann mittlerweile
davon ausgehen dass Cyberangriffe
durchaus tödliche Folgen haben können
wenn sie in der Lage sind bestimmte
kritische Infrastrukturen stillzulegen
wasserstill zuzulegen Energieanlagen
stillzulegen aber dafür bedarf es ein
bisschen mehr Informationen was genau
passiert ist dann lassen Sie uns gerne
mal einen Blick richten auf den
Frontverlauf das passt auch schon gut zu
fragen die wir bei Youtube bekommen und
zwar fragt uns ein User wie stark ist
der Durchbruch bei der Waffe wer war
vielleicht einmal zur Einordnung das ist
im Gebiet SAP sollen ich habe es Eingang
schon gesagt ukrainische Panzer erstmals
hinter dem russischen
Verteidigungsgürtel gesichtet worden
sein
wir sehen das auf der Karte jetzt auch
noch mal gut dass der amerikanische
Think Tank spricht ISW spricht davon
dass es noch zu früh sei von einem
Durchbruch tatsächlich zu sprechen wie
schätzen Sie die Situation dort ein ja
genau ich glaube das ist eine Nachricht
die sich auf gesicherte Informationen
von gestern bezieht das ist auch sehr
richtig man kann nicht jeden jeden
Wimpernschlag der dort passiert
nachvollziehen weil viele Berichte auch
in den sozialen Medien teilweise
übertrieben sind auch übertriebene
Erfolge Melden von daher ist es richtig
dass das zumindest jetzt der gesicherte
Stand ist aber auch da kritisch zu sein
ist auch richtig denn natürlich wird
Russland darauf reagieren russland hat
kein Interesse daran dass dieser
Durchbruch weitergeht das heißt es jetzt
vor allem die Frage ob Russland in der
Lage ist neue Truppen heranzuführen und
quasi dieses dieser Erweiterung dieses
Loch ist jetzt zu stoppen oder aber ob
es den Ukraine gelingt auch diese
Gegenwert zurückzuschlagen und was in
dem Zusammenhang ist wichtig ist darauf
kommen wir gleich noch zu sprechen ist
es ist nämlich nur einer ein
Frontabschnitt an den gekämpft wird
sondern es sind weitere Frontabschnitte
an denen die Aktivitäten hochgehen das
heißt Russland kommt in das Dilemma sich
entscheiden zu müssen wohin es seine
wenigen Reserven jetzt eigentlich packen
möchte genau mein Anschlussfrage wäre
gewesen also sie sagen Russland muss
zusehen wie es mit seinen reservenhaus
haltet worauf kommt es jetzt aus
ukrainischer Perspektive an damit diese
in diesem Fall ist es ja womöglich noch
kein Durchbruch aber damit diese
einzelnen Fortschritte die da erzählt
werden tatsächlich auch zu einem aus
ukrainischer Sicht Erfolg führen können
er ist auf der einen Seite dass man den
Truppen die jetzt diesen Durchbruch
durchführen tatsächlich den den Raum und
die Zeit verschafft weiter voranzukommen
das bedeutet eben Reserven die jetzt
angeführt werden
aufzuhalten so dass sie nicht an die
Front herankommen können Sie im Anmarsch
so wo es immer es geht schon zu
zerstören wenn sie überhaupt unterwegs
sind und damit tatsächlich den den Raum
des Durchbruches der ja schon auf der
Seite wir haben das sind links quasi
also westlich weiter davon schon weiter
vorangeht so breit zu machen dass man
auf einer breiten Front mit gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen hier im Grunde genommen
weiter vorankommen kann aber man muss
auch sagen damit ist es noch nicht zu
Ende man ist noch nicht am
also schon mehr angekommen wir sehen
auch hier noch mal schön auf der Karte
es gibt noch weitere sperlinien die
Frage ist weiterhin wie gut die besetzt
sind durch die Russen also wie gut sie
selber verteidigen können und wie viel
Reserven die Ukraine in der Lage ist
jetzt nach vorne zu bringen damit der
Angriff nicht aufgehalten werden kann
genau sie sagen ein Ziel mehr vor
zurückdenken um dort eben den Russen
auch die Landverbindung zu können
abzuschneiden ist das was das ihrer
Sicht ein ja zeitnah realistisches Ziel
ist das ist ja noch ein ganz schön
weiter Weg dahin ne
ja das ist immer eine Frage von von
Tempo und Risiko ja also man kann
natürlich versuchen einen Durchbruch zu
wagen das kann aber auch bedeuten dass
der schief geht das haben wir ja in der
Anfangsphase gesehen ich glaube nicht
oder ich würde mal so rum sagen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass man jetzt bis
zum also auch schon mehr kommt bzw die
Möglichkeit hat die Logistik im Süden
der Ukraine abzuschneiden ist jetzt
nicht über 50%. das ist aber nicht
schlimm denn die Ukraine plant ja im
Grunde genommen schon für die nächste
Offensive das muss sie jetzt auch tun
die Zeit ist bald abgelaufen um diese
Offensive nach vorne zu treiben aber mit
dem nächsten Jahr kommen natürlich dann
auch neue Waffen wir wissen dass die
amerikanischen Panzer dann eintreffen
werden und das ist im Grunde genommen
das was man jetzt schon ins Auge fassen
muss die Winterzeit auf der einen Seite
und die nächste Offensive die jetzt
vorbereiten muss und besser vorbereiten
muss als die letzte und das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass die Europäer und
Amerikaner ihrem Beitrag leisten müssen
damit es dieses Mal besser läuft als
beim letzten Mal
eine Frage die uns noch bei Youtube
erreicht und zwar von Randolph
Armbruster der fragt gibt es
Informationen darüber ob russische
Kräfte westliche Panzer die beschädigt
wurden für sich selbst einsetzen haben
sie dazu irgendwelche Informationen ich
habe keine Informationen in dieser
Richtung bislang gehört
die Frage ist dann auch wenn sie so ein
Panzer erobert haben müssen sie auch
noch die passende Munition haben die
Munition die die russischen Panzer
verschießen hat nicht das Gleiche
Kaliber wie das der westlichen Panzer in
den meisten Fällen zumindestens
überlegen aber ich glaube das ist so der
Fall das heißt selbst wenn so ein Panzer
haben dann ist das ein schönes
Propaganda Stück dass sie da haben aber
dass sie das einsetzen können auch ohne
das entsprechende Training die Ukrainer
mussten ja auch erstmal auf den
konzentriert werden das ist ja noch eine
zweite Aufgabe also das eignet sich
sicherlich zu einer Art von Propaganda
Parade aber das damit der Mehrwert der
russischen Streitkräfte gestärkt wird
das würde ich eher verneinen okay es
soll ja außerdem Fortschritte aus
ukrainische perspekt Löwe bei bachmut
geben welche Informationen haben Sie
darüber also sowohl bachmute als auch
weiter südlich schreiten offensichtlich
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
schrittweise voran das ist ja eine
Operation gewesen die man sehr
kontrolliert in den letzten Wochen so
gehalten hat dass Russland sich
weiterhin in der Stadt aufhalten konnte
weil es einfach so ein Symbol ist das
nicht aus russischer Sicht eigentlich
nicht fallen darf und eben die Tatsache
dass da jetzt parallel zu der
verstärkten Angriffen im Süden und den
erfolgreichen
taktischen Durchbrüchen im Süden quasi
das Tempo angezogen wird
deutet darauf hin dass man jetzt
tatsächlich in eine Phase kommt wo man
versucht für die russenriedige Probleme
aufzumachen dass sie einfach nicht mehr
wissen wo sie ihre Truppen hinstellen
können denn der
bachmut wie gesagt dass er ein
politisches Symbol weil man enorm viele
Ressourcen da reingesteckt hat das zu
erobern es ist auch in den Gebieten von
denen man Anfang versprochen hat dass
man sie erobern will gleichzeitig ist
der Süden natürlich umso wichtiger denn
sobald die Ukraine amazonischen Meer
stehen ist die Krim wahrscheinlich für
Russland nicht mehr militärisch einfach
oder gar nicht mehr zu verteidigen das
heißt die haben sie zwei Abwägungen die
Russland jetzt schon treffen muss und
dazu kommt noch ein dritter Angriff eine
dritte Front in der Mitte
Hemmerling vielen Dank für den Moment
wir sprechen uns gleich noch mal wieder
der ukrainische Präsident der hat es
vorgestern bei CNN wörtlich gesagt wir
werden bachmut über das wir gerade
gesprochen haben von den Okkupanten
befreien und zwei weitere Städte dafür
braucht die Ukraine natürlich weitere
Waffen um sich eben gegen den russischen
Angriffskrieg zu Wehr zu setzen für
weitere Waffenlieferungen hat Präsident
selenski in dieser Woche in den USA
geworden gestern wurde er da von
Präsident Joe Biden im Weißen Haus
empfangen wir sehen die beiden jetzt das
Ergebnis dieses Treffens ein neues
militärpaket im Wert von
325 Millionen Dollar
ja darüber kann ich jetzt sprechen mit
meinem Kollegen MRT Wissen in Washington
und mit meiner Kollegin Alissa jung die
gerade in Kiew ist in der Ukraine hat es
nämlich in den in den vergangenen Tagen
heftige Angriffe gegeben unter anderem
auf die Infrastruktur Elmer es ist ja
jetzt erst bei diesem bei diesem neuen
Militär Paket das Luftabwehrraketen
geliefert werden sollen Munition für
Raketenwerfer und atillerie Granaten
aber keine Typ keine Raketen vom Typ
attacks mit einer Reichweite von eben
bis zu 500 km jetzt hören wir eben
gerade es sollen doch attackings
geliefert werden warum
ja nach übereinstimmt in den
Informationen amerikanischer Medien und
des ZDF ist es tatsächlich so dass Joe
Biden die Grundsatzentscheidung
getroffen hat diese tacklems zu liefern
das sind ja weitreichende Raketen bis zu
300 km Reichweite und die dienen in
aller erster Linie dazu Nachschublinien
weit hinter der Frontlinie abzuschneiden
aber auch ganz besonders die
Nachschublinien zur Krim haben das ja
vorhin gehört wie wichtig das sein
könnte und man hat sich ganz offenbar
hier in Washington darüber entschieden
nach langen Beratungen diese Raketen zu
liefern warum weil der Winter bevorsteht
weil man das Gefühl hat wann muss jetzt
schauen wie man tatsächlich die
Offensive noch weiter vorantreiben kann
aber vor allen Dingen auch für den
Winter selber denn Russland schießt ja
vor allen Dingen auch von der Krim aus
Raketen und Drohnen in das ukrainische
den Rest des ukrainischen Staatsgebiets
hinein auch nach Kiew und deswegen ist
es so entscheidend dass man
weitreichende Raketen hat nach unseren
Informationen handelt es sich um Modelle
die schon aus älteren best unten sind
die haben Streumunition dabei das
bedeutet dass wenn sie ins Zielgebiet
gelangen dass sie dann eben kleine
Sprengsätze 300 bis 900 Sprengsätze auch
freisetzen und damit kann man besonders
effektiv zum Beispiel auch die Luft
Abwehr der Krim der größte die russische
Luftabwehr der Krim bekämpfen das alles
hat Präsident beiden ganz offenbar
volume silenski versprochen als er
gestern hier in Washington war und vor
einigen Tagen sind nach
zdf-informationen auch die Verbündeten
unter anderem auch die Bundesregierung
über diese Grundsatzentscheidung
informiert worden wir wissen noch nicht
wann genau es geliefert werden und wie
viele es sein werden
Alissa jetzt haben wir gehört der
Angriff auf die Krim mit der
ukrainischen Rakete soll mit einem
Marschflugkörper vom Typ Storm Shadow
durchgeführt worden sein wie haben die
Menschen in der Ukraine auf diese
Nachricht auf diesen Angriff und das
ukrainischer Perspektive erfolgreich
reagiert
du sagst dass der heutige Angriff der
wird natürlich hier in der Ukraine als
Erfolg gewertet von offizieller Seite
haben sich geäußert der Kommandeur der
Luftstreitkräfte der ukrainischen und
auch sein Sprecher und der sagte ich
zitiere das hier mal ganz kurz die
russische Luftabwehr die konnte zum
wiederholten Male nicht damit also
meinte mit den Angriffen fertig werden
to be continued fügt er noch hinzu denn
das war auch nicht der erste Angriff auf
die Krim diese Woche aber mit Sicherheit
natürlich jetzt heute der der hier als
großer Erfolg gesehen wird ist zeigt
also es soll der Bevölkerung auch zeigen
die Krim die ist mit entsprechenden
Waffen erreichbar und sie ist nicht nur
erreichbar sie ist sogar zielgenau
erreichbar und der Sprecher führt auch
noch weiter aus und sagt dieser Angriff
der könnte von Russland nicht mehr
versteckt werden russland werde
oder es werde damit gezeigt natürlich
mit dem Angriff dass die Krim Ukraine
ist und dass sie auch bald befreit
werden das ist natürlich hier die
Hoffnung diese Message message Match
message in diese Nachricht soll das auch
senden und natürlich auch hier wird
gezeigt dass mit diesen Waffen mit
entsprechenden Waffen wenn man die denn
noch nur bekommt theoretisch alles
möglich ist genau das wäre meine Frage
was bedeutet denn tatsächlich denn diese
Ankündigung der USA und doch attackens
an die Ukraine zu liefern für die
Ukraine
das ist genau das was ich gerade schon
kurz angesprochen habe das würde
natürlich bedeuten man ist dazu dann
auch in der Lage also auch weiter
entfernte Ziele zu erreichen man ist
außerdem dazu in der Lage das ist ja
sowieso schon die ganze Zeit Taktik und
Strategie die russische Luft Abwehr eben
auch zu beschäftigen und dann damit aber
auch dann natürlich mit entsprechenden
Waffen ganz zielgenau treffen zu können
denn gleichzeitig darüber könnten wir
vielleicht auch kurz sprechen war das
auch so diese Woche dass natürlich auch
hier in der Ukraine immer wieder heftige
Angriffe auch wieder zustande kamen das
hier heftige Angriffe auf das ganze Land
wieder Erfolg sind zum Beispiel gestern
am Donnerstag wurde zum ersten Mal seit
sechs Monaten die Energie Infrastruktur
wieder angegriffen und auch beschädigt
also insofern sagt die Ukraine natürlich
auch sie braucht entsprechende Waffen um
auch reagieren zu können auf diese
Angriffe die auch in vieler Zeit diese
Woche die schon wieder gegeben hat
genau danach wollte ich Dich noch Fragen
nehmen uns gerne noch einmal mit also
die russische Seite attackiert offenbar
auch die Ukraine gerade massiv was ist
da in den vergangenen Tagen alles
passiert
wir können chronologisch anfangen in
dieser Woche denn es gab tatsächlich
mehrere Angriffe am Dienstag gab es eine
Angriff im Westen auf Lewis auf Lemberg
wie man zu deutsch sagt dabei wurden 300
Tonnen Hilfsgüter zerstört und wir haben
heute mit der Caritas gesprochen die
Caritas hier in der Ukraine denn dort
war ihr größtes Lager für jetzt auch
Hilfsgüter für den Winter das heißt da
wurde jetzt gerade etwas zerstört was
die Caritas sich aufgebaut hat um die
Menschen hier im Winter unterstützen zu
können denn wenn wir uns erinnern
letztes Jahr im Herbst Winter kam es
hier zu heftigen Angriffen zu Strom
Ausfällen zu der Situation dass Menschen
nicht mehr heizen konnten einfach
wirklich für gar nichts Strom hatten und
hier wurde jetzt ein ganz massiver
Schlag verübt auf eben dieses Warenhaus
und dann am Donnerstag also gestern früh
einfach heftige Angriffe in mehreren
Landesteilen auch hier in Kiew wo eben
auch Energieinfrastruktur zerstört wurde
wir haben heute mit dem zuständigen im
Stadtrat gesprochen der sich hier darum
kümmert wie die Menschen in so einem
Fall versorgt werden können der sagt
diese Zerstörung der
Energieinfrastruktur das wird Jahre
dauern sie aufzubauen aber was macht man
jetzt natürlich mittelfristig man muss
sich vorbereiten es ist jetzt
Herbstanfang und man merkt ja jetzt
schon wieder es wird zu diesen Angriffen
kommen er sagte also es wird Jahre
dauern um die Infrastruktur wieder
aufzubauen aber jetzt muss man sicher
irgendwie das Flicken und sich
vorbereiten und das tut man in sofern
dass man wieder diese Sammelpunkte hier
im Stadtgebiet flott macht 700 allein
gibt es kommunale an der Zahl die
letztes Jahr auch intensiv genutzt
wurden das bedeutet immer dann wenn es
keinen Strom gibt können Menschen dort
hingehen so zum Beispiel in Schulen und
können sich dort aufwärmen können ihre
elektronischen Geräte laden und das
befürchtet man eben jetzt ganz massiven
kleinen Vorgeschmack hat man jetzt
darauf schon bekommen diese Woche und
das ist eben erst der Herbstanfang und
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt der dann auch
eine Rolle spielt wir haben auch gedreht
heute in einer Werkstatt für Generatoren
denn wie können die Menschen hier in dem
Empfindlichkeiten Winter in der Ukraine
warm bleiben nur wenn sie irgendwie
Strom haben um es sich warm zu machen da
helfen also Generatoren dabei wir waren
also in einer Werkstatt wo man sehen
konnte
wie diese Generatoren repariert werden
die sollen auch bald ausgeliefert werden
und auch größere Generatoren in
Zusammenarbeit mit den USA schon
geliefert worden sind für eben die
kommunale Infrastruktur für genau diese
Sammelpunkte die ich gerade angesprochen
habe das ist da also die Möglichkeit
gibt dass die Menschen irgendwie durch
den Winter kommen denn alle mit denen
wir hier sprechen haben die Befürchtung
dass es hier wieder also zu massiven
Angriffen kommen könnte und das für die
Menschen hier in sehr ungemütlicher
Herbst und Winter werden könnte
jetzt hören wir gerade bekommen wir
gerade die Eilmeldung das Kanada der
Ukraine in den kommenden drei Jahren
Militärhilfen im Umfang von 482
Millionen Dollar geben will außerdem
will Kanada F16 Trainer auch nach in die
Ukraine entsenden beziehungsweise
entsprechend ausbilden in den USA gab es
ja in den vergangenen Tagen Wochen immer
wieder den Eindruck dass der Rückhalt
für Militärhilfen langsam kleiner wird
worum geht es dabei
ist das so eine Art und ich nehme das
Wort das Republikaner selber dafür
verwenden Geiselnahme von einigen ganz
wenigen innerhalb der republikanischen
Partei im Abgeordnetenhaus hier in
Washington die sowohl der Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus gegenüber der
republikanischen Mehrheit als auch den
Republikanern im Senat gegenüber alles
tun wollen um zu verhindern dass der
neue Haushalt für die USA für das
nächste Jahr verabschiedet wird und dann
wesentlicher Bestandteil in diesem
Haushalt ist natürlich das Militärbudget
und darin stecken eben auch über 20
Milliarden Dollar die ist noch einmal
als zusätzliches Paket für die Ukraine
geben soll darunter 13 Milliarden Dollar
wo es sich wirklich umrüstungsgüter
handelt und das ist für die Ukraine sehr
wichtig deswegen war wo du mir silenski
ihr gestern hier auch im Kongress hat
Gespräche geführt mit den Abgeordneten
und viele Abgeordnete eigentlich sogar
die Mehrheit auch der republikanischen
Abgeordneten stehen unerschütterlich
weiter an der Seite der Ukraine und sind
für die Lieferung sow dieser
attacklungsraketen als auch anderer
Waffen in der näheren Zukunft aber
inwieweit tatsächlich am Ende neue
zusätzliche Gelder zur Verfügung
gestellt werden können hängt so ein
bisschen von diesem Haushaltsstreit und
ich sage es nochmal dieser sogenannten
Geiselnahme ab nächste Woche Ende
nächster Woche läuft im Grunde genommen
die Uhr ab für eine Verlängerung des
Budgets wenn das nicht verlängert wird
dann gibt es hier ein sogenannten
shutdown das heißt die
Regierungsbehörden schließen für die
Zeit bis man eine Einigung gefunden hat
das kann lange dauern und deswegen ist
es glaube ich auch Joe Biden so wichtig
jetzt dieses Signal zu senden hier
selber noch mal über 300 Millionen zur
Verfügung zu stellen inklusive oder plus
eben auch der attackens die in den
nächsten Monaten wahrscheinlich oder
vielleicht schon Wochen geliefert werden
kann
Emma ich würde gerne noch abschließend
eine Frage mitgeben die wir bekommen
haben bei Facebook von Sven Odenthal der
fragt wie sehr wäre denn ein künftiger
US-Präsident an die Zusagen seines
Vorgängers gebunden
eigentlich gar nicht das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen wenn ein neuer
Präsident käme am sandritz 2025 könnte
der natürlich diese Zusagen zurückziehen
oder könnte auch noch mehr Zusagen
machen natürlich hoffen hier alle sowohl
im Weißen Haus der Präsident seinen
Regierungsteam aber auch die Demokraten
im Kongress und auch sehr viele
republikanische Abgeordnete und
Senatoren man muss klar sagen auch unter
denen sind die überwältigende Mehrheit
für eine weitere Hilfe für die Ukraine
also sie hoffen dass es soweit nicht
kommt bis dahin ist noch eine Weile Zeit
und ich glaube das Entscheidende ist das
was selenski hier gestern in Washington
getan hat man stellt hier fragen nach
accountability wie man sagt das heißt er
muss Rechenschaft ablegen wohin das Geld
geflossen ist was genau damit gemacht
worden ist weil immer der Verdacht im
Raum steht dass auch das ein oder andere
in dunklen Kanälen Stichwort Korruption
verschwindet wenn er das tut wenn er
einen konkreten Plan auch weiter
vorlegen kann mit den anderen
Verbündeten wie man zu einem sie kommt
oder zumindest zu Verhandlungen
irgendwann ich glaube so lang bleibt die
republikanische Unterstützung auch bis
zur Präsidentschaftswahl und ein
bisschen darüber hinaus erhalten
danke dir für deine Einschätzung MRT wir
sind in Washington und vielen Dank auch
an Alissa jung die uns aus Kiew
zugeschaltet war danke euch beiden
so wir wollen jetzt noch besser
verstehen wie die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive derzeit vorankommt und
wie sehr Russlands der Ukraine mit
seinen Angriffen schadet und darüber
kann ich jetzt noch mal sprechen mit dem
militär-experten Christian Mödling hallo
noch mal herming hallo guten Abend ja
wir haben gerade gehört die USA wollen
der Ukraine jetzt attackens Raketen
liefern inwiefern erhöht das den Druck
auf Deutschland auch Taurus dann zu
liefern
die Bundesregierung hat ja ihren
Schlingerkurs der nicht antworten in den
letzten Wochen sehr
bewusst fortgesetzt ob man sich dieses
Mal davon bewegen lässt dass die
Amerikaner liefern ist glaube ich nicht
ausgemacht
von das damals bei den Panzern so
gewesen ist ich habe den Eindruck dass
man hier versucht noch weiter auf Zeit
zu spielen und zu hoffen dass
möglicherweise dieses Thema irgendwo
hinten runterrutschen kann man könnte
sogar das Argument jetzt benutzen
dadurch dass sie Amerikaner liefern
müssten die Deutschen nicht wieder
liefern das alles deutet darauf hin dass
man politisch offensichtlich nicht in
der Lage ist ein eigenen Plan sich zu
machen davon was notwendig ist und was
deutsche Anteil an einem erfolgreichen
Plan sein könnte die Ukraine tatsächlich
wieder zurückzubringen in ihre Grenzen
von 1991 das ist alles ein bisschen
schade ist aber politische Realität in
Berlin
wir haben jetzt gerade von meiner
Kollegin Alicia jung aus Kiew gehört das
ist da auch eben massive russische
Angriffe gibt wie sehr wenn man das
einschätzen kann wie sehr schlecht
Russlands der Ukraine derzeit dadurch
dass das kommen würde war absehbar
deswegen hat man ja auch in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten schon
angefangen die Luftverteidigung wiederum
zu erhöhen in den wo immer das ging die
Amerikaner haben noch mal zusätzlich
auch Flakpanzer eingekauft alles das was
möglich ist wird hergeholt weil
natürlich klar ist dass ein wesentlicher
Teil der russischen Strategie Terror ist
muss man aber auch sehen dass dieser
Terror im letzten Jahr auch nicht dazu
geführt hat dass die Ukraine aufgegeben
hat gleichwohl ist die Annahme dass
dieser winterhärter wird als der letzte
im Sinne von einfach nicht dass das
kälter wird sondern einfach das ist
dieses mal schwieriger wird weil
natürlich die Infrastruktur nicht zu
100% wiederhergestellt worden ist das
heißt also hier geht's tatsächlich auch
um die Idee und Moskau hat die Idee man
könne den
verteidigungswillen der Ukraine und
Ukrainerinnen brechen ich glaube das ist
dafür keine historischen präsidenzfälle
gibt das so etwas irgendwie gelingen
kann von daher ist es auch ein gewisser
Art von von Verzweiflung die sich mir
mit Hinterhältigkeit mischt
jetzt haben wir gehört der ukrainische
Präsident selensky spricht von der
Befreiung vom bachmutsmann und sagt man
habe dafür auch Zitat einen sehr sehr
umfassenden Plan wie könnte dieser Plan
ihrer Einschätzung nach Aussehen
ich will den ukrainischen Streitkräften
überhaupt nicht vorgreifen ich glaube
die Sessel Generäle die das machen die
sind nicht sehr glaubwürdig ich glaube
dass man vor allen Dingen aber sagen
kann alles was die Ukraine bislang
angekündigt hat hat sie gemacht ihre
Einschätzung in der Vergangenheit sind
realistisch gewesen auch an den Punkten
wo sie gescheitert es hätte sie das
bekommen was Sie realistischerweise
abgeschätzt hat wäre sie erfolgreich
gewesen oder erfolgreich her zumindest
gewesen als sie es jetzt ist von daher
würde ich sagen lassen wir uns von den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen überraschen
was die Ukraine noch in der Lage ist zu
leisten bis dann leider das Wetter hier
wahrscheinlich einen Strich durch die
Rechnung machen wird oder zumindest die
raumgreifenden Operationen in den
einzelnen Frontabschnitten schrittweise
zu mir liegen bekommen werden weil man
sich einfach nicht mehr mit schweren
Gerät bewegen kann dazu passt sehr gut
die Frage von Ralf wagenleitner die wir
bei Facebook bekommen haben kommt denn
die Gegenoffensive diesen oder erst
nächsten Frühling zum Erfolg wenn sie
eben das ja sich jetzt möglicherweise
verschlechterne Wetter ansprechen ja
die wir werden noch so viele offensiven
sehen wie die Ukraine quasi Reserven hat
ich glaube der der Irrglaube der am
Anfang diesen Jahres auch so ein
bisschen
eingeimpft worden ist es ist das wäre
jetzt die letzte Offensive nein das wird
sie nicht sein denn das Ziel der Ukraine
das politische militärische Ziel ist ja
relativ klar definiert das ist nicht
erreicht das war von da auch relativ
schnell klar dass zwar dieses Jahr
entscheidend sein wird wie es weitergeht
aber dass der Krieg dieses Jahr nicht zu
Ende sein wird also ganz kurz
zusammenfasst ist wird eine neue
Offensive geben das ist keine
Fortsetzung dir dieser Offensive diese
Offensive definiert quasi den Startpunkt
für das nächste Jahr die Ukraine wird
jetzt anfangen müssen die nächste
Offensive zu planen dafür auch den
entsprechenden Ausrüstung und auch das
Personal bekommen müssen damit es
erfolgreicher sein kann als im letzten
Jahr zumindest planbarer sein kann und
gleichzeitig wird man das was man
gewonnen hat verteidigen müssen
ich würde ihn gerne noch zwei Fragen
mitgeben die wir bei Youtube bekommen
haben sehr spitz also sehr sehr
spezifisch speziell weil ich gerade
sagen nein spezifisch und zwar könnte
die Ukraine jetzt nicht unterstützend
auch mehr Lufteinsätze mit den
verbliebenen Nick 29 riskieren daher für
Anfang 2024 die F16 erwartet werden
haben sie dazu eine Einschätzung
jeder Verlust eines Flugzeugs bedeutet
mit hohem Risiko auch im Fluss eines
Piloten das ist glaube ich nicht so
wahnsinnig gut ähm da wo russische
Flugabwehr nicht vorhanden ist wird man
das sicherlich machen
soweit das sozusagen militärisch
sinnvoll ist also spricht da nicht
dagegen dass man aber jetzt sozusagen
nur weil neues Material reinkommt man
nicht nur was mal vorhandene Material
sondern auch die Piloten aufs Spiel
setzen das halte ich für relativ
unwahrscheinlich zu mal ja auch
wahrscheinlich noch ein Teil der der
Flugzeuge die der die der Ukraine jetzt
zur Verfügung stehen in der Lage sind
Waffen zu tragen die die F16 vielleicht
dann auch gerade in dem Moment nicht
kann also daumenschelle oder Skype
die zweite Frage von Daniel g lautet
laut Flugradar wurden ein wurde ein
Aufklärungsflugzeug der NATO kurz vor
und nach dem Angriff auf dem Asowschen
mehr identifiziert bewegt sich die NATO
da nicht auf heißem Eisen haben sie dazu
was mitbekommen ja nein also die
Tatsache alleine dass sie auf
flightradar also einer einer Webpage auf
der Flüge verzeichnet werden weil die
Flugzeuge ihre Transponder anhaben also
quasi ein Funksignal senden zeigt ja das
hier nicht zu verheimlichen ist und das
ist regelmäßig so dass auch die
NATO-Staaten sich ein eigenständiges
Bild über die Lage machen was denn da
genau passiert ist um das selber
bewerten zu können und möglicherweise
auch ein Teil der Informationen an die
Ukraine weiterzugeben hieran ist nichts
was quasi neu im Grunde genommen ist das
findet jeden Tag statt ob das nun
bemannte oder unbemannte Flugzeuge sind
wir unterstützen die Ukraine mit
Informationen damit Sie diesen Krieg
effektiv
weiterführen kann auch diesen Krieg
schneller zu Ende bringen kann dass es
komplett legal und ist sogar geboten
denn hier geht es um die Verteidigung
von jemandem der komplett illegal und
hinterrücks angegriffen worden ist also
eine klare Antwort herrmaling wir
erleben jetzt ja die ganze Zeit ein vor
und zurück beide Seiten reklamieren
immer wieder Erfolge für sich sie haben
es gerade schon angesprochen es wird
auch nicht die letzte gegen Offensive
der Ukrainer sein was muss denn aus
ukrainischer Perspektive jetzt noch vor
dem Winter erreicht werden
also ein vor und zurück sehe ich nicht
ich glaube wir haben einen Diskurs der
immer wieder versucht zu erklären wir
hätten ihren Stillstand oder die
Offensive käme nicht voran selbst der
diese Woche ja noch mal getitelt das ist
etwas überraschend vor dem Hintergrund
dass die Erfolge die dort auf den Karten
aufgezeichnet werden ja Objektiv
nachweisbar sind und überhaupt nicht
bestritten werden also von daher da
gibt's kein vor und zurück sondern es
gibt einen sehr langsames mühsames und
auch sehr blutiges Vorrücken der Ukraine
hat dass sie mit viel mit viel Aufwand
betreiben müssen das was passieren muss
ist das die Ukraine ich sag jetzt mal
was überraschendes so viel Reserve
halten dass das was Sie gewonnen haben
tatsächlich auch über den Winter
gehalten werden kann das ist ein viel
wichtigeres Ziel als die Idee man müsste
jetzt noch die die Küste des Asowschen
Meers sehen können oder sogar reinfahren
können das ist es nicht wenn es gelingt
in dieser Phase tatsächlich noch sowas
zu kommen dass man die Logistik mit
Blick auf die entsprechenden Ost-West
verlaufenden Eisenbahnen und Straßen
nicht erreicht aber zumindest sie unter
Beschuss nehmen kann dann ist ein
nächster Punkt erreicht wo die
Lebenslinien der russischen Streitkräfte
immer dünner werden ist immer
schwieriger wird diese Streitkräfte zu
versorgen was natürlich auch im Winter
einfach ein riesiges Problem werden wird
den auch für die russischen Soldaten
steigt der Bedarf an an Energie mit
denen sie sich selber am Leben erhalten
können also das wäre sicherlich ein
großer Vorteil und ein guter Startpunkt
in die Offensive des nächsten Jahres
dann abschließend gerne noch die Frage
von TomTom 34b Herr Mölling wie weit
sind die Ukraine denn damit ihre eigene
Waffenindustrie aufzubauen damit sie
sich künftig eigenständig versorgen kann
ja das ist seit Beginn des Krieges
eigentlich ein Forderung oder Finger
zeigt die die wir mit einigen Kollegen
aufgestellt haben dass man die Ukraine
sehr schnell und systematisch eigentlich
nicht nur das westliche Verteidigung
sondern rüstungssystem integrieren kann
die Ukraine hat in einigen Bereichen
sicherlich sehr viele Kenntnisse jetzt
durch den Krieg gewonnen in anderen
Bereichen würde sie davon profitieren
wenn sie Produktionskapazitäten selber
erhielte weil sie einfach noch
wahrscheinlich gute Menschen hat die
Ukraine war vorher rüstungsproduzent ist
es jetzt auch noch wie weit die
Installation noch da sind weiß ich nicht
aber hier gibt's ein großen Bedarf und
wahrscheinlich auch eine große großen
Willen Wunsch der Ukraine tatsächlich
hier in sogenannte Joint Ventures also
gemeinsame Kooperationen mit
europäischen Staaten und amerikanischen
Staaten einzutreten um auch die
Eigenständigkeit für die Produktion
wieder herzustellen und gleichzeitig ein
Beitrag zu leisten um die Europäer zu
entlasten bei der Versorgung damit auch
eine eigene Kontrolle über die eigene
Rüstungsindustrie wiederherzustellen
sagte der Militärexperte Christian
Mödling vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
für die Einschätzung heute Abend sehr
gerne schönen Abend Ciao danke ihnen
soweit unserer ZDF hatte live zu den
aktuellen Entwicklungen im Ukraine Krieg
wenn ihr dazu auf dem neuesten Stand
bleiben wollt dann schaut am besten
vorbei in unserer ZDF heute App danke
fürs zuschauen danke für eure Fragen und
Gedanken und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss